say you don't like other guys [ __ ]
your wife and that's what's causing all
this stress and trouble for you and and
and stop trying to like evolve past it
you know like you don't like when guys
[ __ ] your wife which is the most
relatable thing
right like
i would not like if guys [ __ ] my wife
i would hate that dude i would hate that
and there's one thing that i could do
which would be divorce her so that guys
wouldn't [ __ ] my wife anymore because it
wouldn't be your wife because she
wouldn't be my wife and it's just like
and he's like you're ready first of all
the the audacity to write like a what
he's been saying self-help book like
when guys [ __ ] your wife there's just
something about
people [ __ ] your wife all right
montreal first time yeah it's my first
time no no no dude i've been here a lot
a lot yeah and you didn't have haitian
food no i haven't had haitian food you
didn't bring me [ __ ] because you don't
believe in it i believe in it you don't
believe me i know that's a rush
ain't no rush dude i'm chilling fine i'm
ordering right now let's go
let's go
i was asleep o'clock bro i'm 38 i can't
be up to five in the morning
but well i was saying to y'all before
and i mean this sincerely i think
montreal has uh
i i think per capita maybe best looking
women in
on the east on the east side oh no it's
cold
dude it's up there with north america
bro i think it's the best look in north
america i imagine in terms of like the
men to women ratio and i mean
that's crazy okay
and they and and and they don't they
don't have games ugly they don't have
you know listen
you don't have to do much i mean we're
married out here you know what i mean so
fair but you don't have to which is not
deserving this is observations you don't
have to do much but it's true
i'm trying to bail him out he's not even
agreeing with me bro
i worked in the industry brett okay what
you talking about okay okay let's see
what i've seen so yeah so the girls here
are stunningly beautiful also i think
there's like um
i don't think you guys get enough sun
to [ __ ] their skin up like
does that make sense
i'm being serious that makes sense like
like white women age pretty well here
yes and i really think it comes down to
that like it might be a sun thing no
it's kind of like a tom brady thing
where everybody thinks there's a cliff
coming but it just seems to get pushed
back and push back that's the same thing
with white women here but eventually
they're gonna fall off
you think oh yeah they do i think that's
only a norwegian thing like if you like
because like mediterranean white women
don't fall off no no must be like the
olive oil or some [ __ ] that's it yeah
that's it they don't fall off they don't
fall off a lot italians and greek women
they they do yeah they stretch it out
yeah
when they got a good hand
when they got dealt with a good hand
when they don't ain't no recording that
look how long it is for you to find a
haitian restaurant because they don't
have them i'm talking stuff
you talking about
uncles and [ __ ]
yo please invent some food and bring it
over here
so we can act like we got cuisine
when i moved here seven years ago i was
shocked wait a minute where are you from
father girl i've lived all over us i
lived in ottawa i lived in uh ethiopia
for some time i lived in los angeles so
i lived all over oh okay but you were
born where i was born in ottawa but i
grew up in ethiopia
wait i didn't know you grew up in
ethiopia
oh [ __ ]
oh wow
yeah so i got my canadian citizenship
and peace the [ __ ] out i donated to you
man
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i heard all them joking damn
diggy how are you this thick i'm like
bro don't ask no questions no that's no
question all the money i took all the
money
all
i was shocked by how attractive the
women were and i was grateful for how
ugly the dudes were yeah zero to little
no competition the ratio is is
staggering and why is that you think
also also they really like care about
themselves canada is a wild place but
you have to understand that the people
that you say montreal
no no okay okay so montreal is and i
mean this sincerely it seems like i'm
just stroking but like we were out last
night and like you know we travel for a
living right like we're in all the
cities and there's few
great cities
in the world and by that i mean like you
can find greatness in every city right
like i was in cleveland i'm sure we can
go to like some restaurant that like has
some really unique experiences
but like there's few cities like like we
were in new orleans not too long ago
right and it's like i don't want to seem
like just the french-inspired ones on
fire because then french people have too
much of ego on that but like but like
new orleans was one of those places
where you go and you're like ah you
gotta come here yes like you have to
spend some time in new orleans montreal
is one of those cities and i think a lot
of americans still haven't discovered
montreal and they haven't discovered new
orleans either yeah yeah but i got the
mardi gras [ __ ] so people are at least
familiar with it but mardi gras is its
own like time of year where the city is
completely different and people
say this because like even if you ask
preach i tell people if i was to live in
america and i could choose any city if
like if that city wasn't in america
would i live there it'd be new orleans
really i always say that i love
everything about i like the mods linux i
like the fact they can't bury they're
dead everything has to be above ground i
like the fact that the houses are all
shut down
houses painted in every color yeah that
cows are crazy they can't bury their
dead because they're flooded yes because
the bodies
right but then it's also like you go
down to you go to the french quarter and
there's like a band on every corner
there's amazing jazz people can walk
around vibe with the city crazy it's the
most one of the most unique in the movie
it's always a party yes even even a
funeral is a [ __ ] party yeah and
these are just like the southern manors
are there too so people are mad kind to
each other so my time in new orleans was
like fantastic so i get what you say in
terms of that vibe and i feel the same
way about this city as well yeah it's in
the summer flavor in the summer that's
the thing in the winter this [ __ ] is
brutal but in the summer even yo even
come like spring and stuff like that
it's not that bad yeah people coming out
it is fire yeah so you went to that
columbia city you had some fun i was
just like i don't go clubbing like that
man i'm married you know what i mean i'm
like chilling we're on the road but like
i was in this spot and i was like wow
the women
nah yeah i was like wow but here's the
thing about what's interesting about
canada is like
it's so progressive right
but the women still really lean into
traditional beauty standard [ __ ]
like it's not like so progressive that
they shave the side of their [ __ ]
head and they're like strapping their
teeth out there yeah like it's like it's
like it's like we're equal but i'm gonna
get lip injections and i'm gonna make
sure they're crazy they got waves they
got waves they got waves this beat
there's some people that do that
definitely i was like no no no they
don't they don't do that [ __ ]
yeah they got away the biggest smith
yeah they got like a whole fate of [ __ ]
no no but they have ways of people
growing their heart that those people
there are definitely people like that
okay i'm not gonna say like yeah no it's
not like that you just seen a parcel of
it you've just seen a little bit of it i
seen the little bougie part a little a
little part of it but there's the rest
of them is definitely there absolutely
a guy said to me yesterday he goes uh
he's i think he's from here he goes
you go to toronto you could meet a girl
and you know me i love [ __ ] toronto i
stand toronto but like he goes you can
meet a girl
that
is white
asian black
anything and they're all similar
personality-wise right and then he said
the great thing about montreal is
people hold on to like their
their culture a little bit more so like
you're meeting these different type of
people in this place do you think that
that's true or you think this guy was
just coked up oh it depends for what
depends for who okay it depends for what
it is like it's it's like do people fall
into a montreal archetype
or
i think i think what you saw is not you
keep saying canada's dope which you saw
i never it's not
i never said that you never said that
don't put words in my mouth put haitian
food in my mouth
already on the way don't worry it's not
the way it's not the way but
it's like you said oh yeah you love cat
you see montreal yeah once y'all is not
canada
toronto is not canada oh but is that in
the same way that like l.a is not
america or new york is not america like
in a way
if people base their opinion of america
based off earlier new york i feel like
they'd have a very warm perception
yeah most of america is not one but then
but then what is a country is a country
your most famous cities
where you
you know export the most culture or is
it where the most people live
because the majority of the people in
that country are not in those big
they're not at all so but they're
represent really like america will
represent canada is not much y'all
exactly like what the waitlist for
example the way people vote here
montreal is one thing the rest of the
province is another thing
just in the way they vote yeah your
rules were crazy yeah the rules and
rules were crazy they were crazy but
outside it was mad chill yeah it's the
same thing if you go to france they'll
be like yo france is not paris no
everybody's personal tell you that
everyone outside of paris hates paris oh
i thought that they love it i thought
they'd have ah nah no because they're
really entitled people from pur [ __ ]
yeah they really they they really look
different they live differently yeah
everybody everybody whenever you talk to
a french person or you're oh you're from
france yeah so you're you're from
bahrain no i'm not they really
disassociate themselves from paris yeah
they do yeah they do they do and
the people from paris they're proud yo
can i say something i was in paris with
my wife a little while ago yeah
it was it was so like
homogeneous like like it was so similar
to new york like i like traveling to
like
to go away yes and by go away i don't
mean literally physically i mean like i
want to be immersed in the culture i
know nothing about like okay i just take
you to a different just take me a
different place let me it's like a
fantasy it's like sci-fi you know what i
mean like these kids play dungeons and
dragons i go to [ __ ] mexico city
right and it's just like show me
something i don't know about a life i
don't understand you don't want to see
[ __ ] playing dungeon and dragon
in mexico exactly the same time
there's a czar in new york because it's
like i'm walking down the streets i'm
like it's all the same restaurants all
the same stores yeah yeah that's what
toronto i think the issue with toronto
is is like when i go down there i feel
like everybody's shopped at nordstrom
rack
and i don't feel any kind of
individuality generally when i'm in that
seat i don't feel that like that vibe
and i think part of it is due to like
the pricing of the place how everyone's
getting priced out slowly but surely and
i feel like just the vibe of the general
spot it's like it's got diversity but
also like it's just mostly ugly
diversity so like the most people are
like kind of nasty yeah right so they
got a bit everything but it's not great
you know where's here i feel like it's
opposite and also i think what do you
mean it's kind of ugly first yeah
which countries make up yeah
it's like they allowed them to immigrate
but it's just the ugliest people are
allowed in toronto
[Music]
and i know because i've been out there
today that's just true
but i'll say much are the big difference
and i think why people feel like i need
to start accepting some ukrainians
[Music]
oh definitely yeah they've already let
in a bunch but much specifically there's
so many universities and [ __ ] like that
and so so many people come here to go to
school yeah and so it's got a lot of
youth as a result
from all over and um yeah i think that's
like one of the biggest reasons also
this is a city that's very accessible
and affordable yeah most people here
have a good quality yeah okay little for
rent they go out they go to the park
they go to work out they wear whatever
they want and and they work part-time
and they can have a decent life whereas
i feel like when you're struggling it's
hard to look there's there's a lot of
people
there's a lot of people are gonna talk
[ __ ] and say like no man the rent is
expensive you know compared to compared
to new york yeah compared to toronto
compared to
vancouver so what's the spot like what
is like uh i'll give you an example i
got a three bedroom apartment downtown
i'm paying 1100 a month
it's a huge apartment
see this spot right here
17.
what
yeah yeah rent prices here so that's why
i moved here to do college because i
couldn't afford to live anywhere else
and i could get regular spots here and i
wanted to do stand up seriously so i was
like i can't go anywhere else on this
budget so i'm like let me just move here
i can pay my rent with nothing and just
work and write and be downtown you do
youtube full time and this [ __ ]
don't want to [ __ ] he doesn't want to
drive i understand in the city it's a
bit of a [ __ ] yeah right but
if you don't want to do that then you
have to be downtown where every thing is
at but then after that you have to pay
for this and that's it to move so if
your rent is already crazy and then the
uber's now is crazy and then everything
is crazy like you're drilling your
pocket you're shocked
everybody can't believe it that's the
rent the rent is just yeah
i mean you guys don't even want to know
what i pay in rent no we don't i i can
imagine no we don't i got i got a condo
you got a condo uh
and it was
250. where
just just on the other side of the bench
it's like if i it's like if i lived
about to cry
poor thing
yeah it's stuff like that and yeah it's
rising and there's been like some
bubbles since since uh the the covid
situation happened but it's nothing
compared i got cousins in cambria
heights in in
in queens what they pay
ridiculous ridiculous crazy stupid i
will never these guys still can't
believe it yeah like and whenever
whenever we like trying to make sense of
it is it is it because it's hard to live
and work here if you're not bilingual so
less people can move here no you can you
can work here because a lot of people do
not speak to language oh so it's not me
all but and if you go in the rest of the
province most of the people
a lot of the people i'm gonna say most
but a lot of people they don't need to
speak english oh no that's what i'm
saying like there's less people in
canada that can move here and work
because they don't speak french and
speaking french is a requirement if you
want to get a good job right
yes to some degree but i don't think
it's that i don't think it's that i
don't think he said first first off they
had an abundance of apartments for a
long time yeah and so they always had
vacancies so prices were always decent
but a lot of markets are inflated for no
reason yeah a lot of the rep prices
don't actually make sense just say the
reason why bro but because the reason
you're not wrong but in montreal there
was a lot of there's a lot of people
that came from france
actually and since the france the french
people were used to pay a lot more for
the prices
the the landlords were like oh okay yeah
this how much is this oh this is 700.
it's just 700. i paid four thousand oh
really no it's a thousand two yeah yeah
and it's just got it just got up in
certain regions and stuff like that
markets are just inflating themselves
yeah some degree to unreasonable even
like
housing prices how much they increased
over the course of pandemic none of that
is actually based off of the real value
but the market has just been insane and
people have been trying to buy at such
crazy rates even though like people are
buying like regular ass houses like 300k
above the market price so whatever
they're listening
yeah people can't buy houses anymore no
because like they see a house listed at
600 000 they go to and like somebody
already bought it for 300k
base what what kind of evaluation is
that yeah and so you just realize it's
such a frenzy and such a weird spot
right now so when i look at prices in
other places i'm like it doesn't have to
be this hot but because everyone else
around them is raising their price like
[ __ ] i'm trying to make more money yeah
but the landlord is just increasing
increasingly
it shouldn't be like that we have good
rent control here too which is useful
because i know in some places you could
have rent at 1100 one year like yeah
it's hundred next yeah a hundred percent
here they can only raise it by like ten
fifteen bucks a year they're not allowed
and yeah yeah just so you can already do
more fifteen bucks but i'm like all
right
if they do more they have to justify by
big uh like you did big renovation or
something like that you did something if
you didn't do nothing you can't justify
that you increasing more than five
percent you can't so it sucks to be a
landlord here
oh yes or no you got recourse but yes it
it it can suck like it definitely sucks
if you guys started investing in real
estate and buying properties like doing
it here might not be the most
advantageous it's not like vancouver
where it's the opposite where the the
vancouver landlords have uh much more
they have much more power
well that was the issue i think with
china right it was vancouver right
didn't they make like pass a law saying
foreign investments i think they taxed
it differently because it was such an
issue for a long time i think i kind of
like that like yes i need to look into
this a little bit more but i don't like
the idea of like somebody else and i'm
sure americans we do this all the time
we go go to some like island and we just
buy up a bunch of land and the people
that actually live on the island can't
even buy a place where they actually
live and yeah they can't move out yeah
you know
americans gentrify whole countries yeah
yeah it's not just let's go
you know what i'm saying
who's next
no but so i i could see the frustration
if you're like some kid growing up in
vancouver yeah and they're they're like
there's chinese investment that's buying
up all these condos but they ain't even
living there it's one thing if you move
and live there right run it but if
you're just gonna hold it empty and now
i can't buy a place it's like a bank
that's where they hold their money that
thing is an investment
yeah that's their bank yeah they come in
with the money
they come in with the money and it's
just a transfer from one so they can't
verify where it's from on that end that
bank's paying you more
and then they transfer the money here
and they're like where's that where's
that money from off from my banking gal
what are you doing over there
find out yeah go ahead and find out and
then they come here they just store it
in the bank yeah so they just it's it's
their banks i think it should be in
favor of the tenants i think generally a
society benefits when most of the
tenants have accessible
housing because i think when things are
so expensive you're working so many
hours just trying to make rent yeah like
and most you know most folks live
paycheck to paycheck yeah that's not a
right wing no it's not but when you have
no financial flexibility whatsoever due
to like
housing or whatever it costs it's like
you can't afford to invest in any other
things in any endeavors and any kind of
artistic expressions any kind of good
quality of life everything is just like
i gotta work to pay my bills by the end
of the month and if you get on any hard
times you're [ __ ] beautiful whereas
here because it was kind of an untouched
market for a long time we had the
flexibility to actually live like my
quality of life when i moved here
shot up through the roof i started going
out to random events i started showing
up to like
i just you couldn't enjoy art
yeah i was like oh this is what it's
like when i go out with friends to the
restaurant i go check my account every
time
rent is easy like i don't have to stress
that and i was not making a lot of money
but because everything was so affordable
it took such a burden off my shoulders
and so i could only imagine because i
haven't lived in other places like when
you got kids or you got other
obligations and you just trying to make
your bills it's so [ __ ] stressful
yeah but so we look at us right
i'm like whoa that's crazy no that's not
what's crazy what's crazy is your
situation where you got to pay five
grand a month to get some apartment or
some condo that's a price
for the landlord that's [ __ ] up too
because it's so hard for for the
landlords to evict someone at some point
yeah it takes some time it takes some
time and it happened to us yeah where we
have to invict [ __ ] and it took
a whole lot like it took a year and a
half and by the time you eat that the
whole year you got to eat that and
you're not getting that money back
because yes look wherever you go to a
landlord whatever uh property
association whatever when you go there
they tell the tenant you got to pay the
[ __ ] back you think you're
getting paid you're not getting paid how
are you going your money's gone yeah
yeah so that's a year and a half that's
you don't have that money and you have
yeah yeah you got to evict that
[ __ ] i met my and you got
sometimes you got to show up when they
move you got to be there yeah cause
these i've seen people leave with uh
light bulbs
they're my light bulbs [ __ ] i put
yeah they try to take everything they
take every doors really gay
people are sad you got to be super
scrutinizing when you're picking a
tenant that's why that's why they asked
for a deposit that's why they asked for
another job that's why they asked for
for some time to try for like they need
they go they're gonna check their crew
your credit they're gonna check it
because they don't know who is you
that's why i think balance is good i
don't think it should be completely
lopsided like that yeah that's
ridiculous but i do think that cities
that employ some form of rent control is
really important because i do think like
landlords over the course of a year
taking their thing from one thousand to
three thousand two thousand i think
that's ridiculous and i think it like
changes the the feel of a neighborhood
to such a degree that don't like it oh
man we were at we had an interesting
privilege discussion we um i'm i'm
curious we were talking i was talking to
the boys about this one curious you guys
opinions on this is do we sometimes
confuse privilege for
the way it should be
all this yeah like like
black people you shouldn't be pulled
over for no reason right
the fact that i don't get pulled over
for no reason
isn't privileged it's the norm it's the
norm so are we getting caught up in this
word
my my fear is this word turns white
people off because it's like i'm some
poor white [ __ ] and you know
barely paying rent whatever and then
you're going to walk around telling me
how privileged i am i'm like [ __ ] you i
don't even want to listen to this [ __ ]
right so now i'm turning away from the
discussion when i i should easily be
able to acknowledge it's it's almost
like deficit the black black d
we'll talk about instead of white
privilege it's black deficit right right
and it's like
how do we bring that up to bare minimum
instead of saying
this [ __ ] that's normal is a privilege
and society it's not working
like i have constitutional rights that's
the rights well the thing is the thing
is the cops are allowed to pull you over
anybody they're allowed to pull maybe
that was a poor example no no no no
if they're allowed to pull anybody over
right and so is it that they're not
doing their job when they're not pulling
you over
or they're doing their job too good with
us
so the fact that they slack on you is
your privilege so that's the that's the
other side of the coin
i get what he's saying in that like
with the difference in maybe the
marketing of the word how it kind of
comes across to me i say like i don't
like using the word privilege for for
kind of that reason because to me i
always say privilege is oftentimes just
the absence of a stress yeah meaning
right like
a privilege that men might have versus
women is like we don't have to deal with
the periods yeah right like listen say
what you want that shit's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] having to bleed the whole thing
privilege right that's why they say
something there's an absence of a
certain stress that you have to deal
with in the same way there's ways that
women can be like privileged in some
ways right the problem i think that i
have generally with like the whole idea
like white privilege or black purge or
this privilege is like oftentimes it's
too much of a binary where we just look
at like white and then everything else
yeah right and generally
if you know anything about life it's
like people are privileged in so many
different ways absolutely and in ways
that oftentimes are more important than
race itself right like we'll talk about
financial problems there's literally no
privilege better being right into a rich
family
a rich country yes we had
nothing bad in life just based off where
they're born they can't travel to
anywhere right without getting like a
long visa application so i just we did a
video once
yes and we did like 30 different ones we
got like we had tears yeah we got beauty
privilege we had hey man females what
would you rather be i said it too
remember we said that [ __ ] we said
would you rather be an ugly an ugly
white man or a very handsome black man i
said i'll take a handsome black
blackmail any day
because being attractive has more
benefits than being a white person
and then my group of friends well i got
i got i got white friends and indulge in
that group
when i was growing up guys
i don't
[Laughter]
i got more privilege than them just in
the way i was brought up interesting the
way i was growing up because
i was able to travel i traveled really
young with my parents
right i was able to see other [ __ ]
because my parents my parents are still
together that's another privilege so we
got to give you like a privilege score
like they do like with nba 2k players
where like we just have all the
different rankings together
yeah your attractiveness your wealth
your access to you know i guess certain
rights i just feel like the the
privileged discussion
is is an important one but i think that
sometimes we get bogged down it's just
like a word to thrown out to like shut
people up like check your privilege is
the polite way of saying stop talking
yeah have you have people said that to
you have you heard that how much of a
real phrase that is right no no no no no
no no for real i've heard it you guys yo
i've heard bro you know how real that is
i've heard white women say that too oh
that they're they're the ones who use it
yeah i heard a white woman say that to
me i wasn't even sure now girls like uh
yeah you're a man like [ __ ] yeah i'm a
black man yeah yeah and then she shut
the [ __ ] up but she was she was throwing
you to check your pillows
[ __ ] check yours yeah you check yours
and then she sat the [ __ ] down but yeah
yeah they use it on me that's your
privilege i don't know i just feel like
there is a good nuance discussion to be
had here but i don't want people to
confuse like normalcy with privilege
because you should feel entitled to
normalcy right we don't have to feel
entitled privilege like if if somebody's
following you around the store because
you're black and they're not following
me around the same store that's not my
privilege yeah but that's your br that's
your privilege that they're slacking on
you because basically them following you
the store but they're not supposed to
follow you around
what they're supposed to do is the
regulator which is how things are you
know what i'm saying it's like yeah
what's the standard in society do you
are you treated to a better standard
than others yeah and if so is that
fairly done and then i think that's
where the word privilege comes into play
but again what if that standard is based
on laws and legislation right so it's
like and you're not getting the respect
of those laws none of that matters
because what matters is really how it's
enforced you could put any law on any
books how are they applying it that's
what matters because you can have a law
that defends you from theft but if it's
never applied is that law even real
people
in part
i hear what you're saying here um
because we do have a bunch of uh you
know uh antiquated laws like uh you know
the five women can't be in a room
together the brothel law like all these
laws from like the 1500s and [ __ ] but
like i'm turning i'm talking about
specific in terms of like using that
word
i feel like you should be entitled
to what laws say
you have the right to do we agree and
and i think if you get those
entitlements that should just be bare
minimum normalcy
and whereas if it's not something that's
legislation then we can look into
treatment and stress and those type of
things and start labeling things as
privilege but like in terms of being
like harassed when you're not supposed
to be harassed yeah right i don't know i
just i just see why people turn off at
the discussion yeah and it's an
important discussion and maybe it's
because i have a diverse group of
friends and i'm like now like if we
actually broke this down right here it'd
be a little bit better instead of just
like throwing out [ __ ] buzzwords i
think i i agree with that point i think
there's certain words i avoid using
conversations because i know it's
pointless i'm talking to dudes i'm like
man toxic masculinity yeah yeah yeah
there's certain words i just shut it
down i think there's ways you can talk
about the topic without using words that
are so loaded you know what i'm saying
it's like you can look at somebody and
talk about their behavior without being
like hey you're a racist piece of [ __ ] i
mean sometimes granted they are being
that and so there may be a discussion
for that but oftentimes the words are
just overused in the situation it's not
necessary it's like if i'm talking to
you i'm not going to try to
explain everything you're doing there's
no point of that just let me talk
i mean oh what are you doing right now
is toxic masculinity yeah yes [ __ ] i am
okay
what i was saying is you explaining and
and and dissecting everything i'm saying
just let me get to my point yeah let me
get to my my thing and then after that
you'll see it's a way to avoid
discussion problems yeah basically
you're just you're just you're
gaslighting i've been using this [ __ ] on
my wife all the time
all the time every time we argue i'm
like gosh love it
all the time i love that [ __ ] bro
bro bro oh my god i had the best [ __ ]
we're in the bahamas we're in the casino
dude like this is something i'm
realizing i really like because i can't
tell my wife what to do
so when like
people can i root for them
like like when she like breaks a rule or
something and the security goes like you
can't be here like i'll be like go tell
her you know like tell her like tyler
get the [ __ ] out of here
so my wife was we were like we were
playing like blackjack and she was
trying to cross through the casino pit
and you know you're not allowed to be in
the middle of the tables right but so
she crosses she gets like to like the
middle and he goes miss you have to go
back and i know already what my wife is
going to say because you could be a pain
in the ass no no
wait wait say it again i'm already
halfway
son
she goes she goes she go and i literally
go she goes she's more than halfway i
know her little pain the answer and she
goes she i literally see her about it
she just goes i'm already closer to the
other side like i'm already halfway and
the second she said that just to be a
pain in the ass i was like yo get here
whenever we do security there's a
husband there's like oh i'm gonna have a
i'm gonna have an argument with two
people yeah yeah it started with one
this one yeah dude
and then this mama's like get up
[Applause]
you got to protect her from security
well you got a wife bro you got to
protect her from your herself yourself
you being a piece of [ __ ] right now walk
your ass back
thank you i needed that one i did this
small victory
did your wife acknowledge you she was
furious at me because i was at the table
going do it
in front of the whole casino i was like
yeah let her know just get past
how you just gonna think you can go
anywhere
everybody thinks she's just a jackass no
he's the husband
right oh yeah oh you're gonna take his
side i believe in the rules
we have to abide by the rules
about that exactly because you're
privileged
you mad cause
babe i'm only halfway in this [ __ ] is
that cheating
[Laughter]
how's the response been for you uh to
the whole will smith saga i mean it's
kind of been dragging on it almost feels
like a week now bro it was a week
we had we put uh we put like a little
roast at the beginning of the episode i
saw that that was brilliant thank you
man
thank you and uh that [ __ ] is our
biggest episode ever yeah 2.2 we got is
that two point two two point two holy
[ __ ]
man
but it was great
we hit two
that's crazy yeah man so like that and
then just clipping and putting it out
that was just i mean it was just crazy
just went
went viral
but uh
i was just it was a cool moment it was
just i mean for us like creatively like
content-wise and i feel like it's a good
reaction i think most comedians had i
think i had a very good reaction to it
yeah yeah yeah cause it was like weird
it's like you're defending your tribe
and it's cool to do that yeah and you
get to do it using the thing that like
you know how to do
just being funny yeah he's like you
can't say jokes and it's like well here
we go
yeah what do you guys think about it
yeah i i think it's it's the right
reaction i think most of us
i think on the surface all agree
violence is probably not the smartest
response no more sensible civilized
society just being violent against
somebody who said things you didn't like
yeah right
probably isn't the most sensible so i
think comedians just coming back with
jokes or whatever they had in their
pockets or whatever it takes they had i
was like i was really glad to see that
rather people just yelling on the screen
you [ __ ] you know what i mean like they
came at it and i think in a way that
really highlights the strength of what
comics do i think
i don't know if you were like this for
me like i felt it on a visceral level
for some reason this one like really
bothered me for a lot the reaction of
people around it the action itself and
then as i said on it more it's also like
what will smith represents and like what
that moment was it was like it really
resonated me
much more than i thought it would
i've been thinking about it pretty much
the entire week because i'm like
there's so much there there's so much
there and you know one of the things
that really kind of stuck out to me
is
i i i don't know why but you said
something during one of her videos that
we filmed yeah i remember what i said
you said you said if that was ricky
gervais do you think he would have put
his hands on him right i don't think you
would have and i think and i think with
black men specifically like the way that
we hold on to our masculinity
it's very personal
you know and will smith himself i
remember he talked about how he's felt a
coward most of his life one of his
memoirs he talked about that in depthly
and i felt like in that moment when i
saw him get up there i felt like that
was like a very fragile man reacting
yeah impossible it was not strong it was
not strong in my whole life definitely
to the slightest defense you know what
i'm saying yeah but that was that was
most of our youth right that was really
that i was that was not will smith the
man that was will smith the kid yeah i
mean popping off like that and the white
when i said about i really thought you
brushed it up you brushed it off when
when i said that i thought you're like
man whatever i don't think so but it's
funny that you thought about it but yeah
i really think that if it was a white
man there because of the relationship
that we have with a white man and the
relationship that we have with oh [ __ ]
it's going to be
then the media would have been some
other thing
i think the media would have been like
yeah
a white man putting down on black women
and then the black man it would have
been viewed differently as well
it would have
it would be more acceptable actually if
it not people wouldn't accept it more
like i mean quiet america bible belt
would have been like oh my god
you know i mean they look like
i think it would have been the thing
like that but the media would have been
like yeah a white man putting down a
black woman and a black man stand up he
would have been on a whole ass pedestal
but he wouldn't he wouldn't have done it
he would have probably got up and
shouted but to walk up to the dude yeah
and slap him it's like working it's not
working having a job when you're getting
disrespected by your boss and walking
your boss and not quitting yeah but
slapping the [ __ ] there's our
whole relationship that we have as well
with white people and
with with us within the community now
here's the question though okay
would chris rock have made that joke
about beyonce
i'm pretty sure he would've
oh because of jay-z you think
no i i don't know i think jada's less
respected than beyonce i don't think
that chris respects jada
i don't think i think they but bro yeah
i think that he sees her as like will's
wife
nobody does that and that may be true
but i don't know i don't know if chris
is making that joke about beyonce it was
it was already a thing whenever
she was talking about she was
protesting about oscar so white yeah and
she's like
everybody turned into a whole ass chris
brown
yeah
and then get in you can't even get in
like stop stop talking you're not
invited yes you know what i mean she
made it really difficult for for chris
rock because when he agreed to host that
and she was critical of that and then
every interview he did about hosting
those oscars became about if he was
sellout or not exactly and then after
that and then after that you have the
whole fact that she hasn't stopped
opening her mouth about her goddamn
relationship and everything else so it's
everybody opening her mouth a lot is the
problem
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
leave the issue here
so that so so i don't think it's not
even chris rock it's everybody everybody
laughed at those jokes hard i always i
wish [ __ ] will could just be honest
bro i was like
say you don't like other guys [ __ ]
your wife and that's what's causing all
this stress and trouble for you and and
and stop trying to like evolve past it
you know like you don't like when guys
[ __ ] your wife which is the most
relatable thing
right like
i would not like if guys [ __ ] my wife
i would hate that dude
i would hate that and there's one thing
that i could do which would be divorce
her so that guys wouldn't [ __ ] my wife
anymore because it wouldn't be your wife
because she wouldn't be my wife right
and it's just like and he's like you're
ready first of all the the audacity to
write like a but he's been a self-help
book like
where do you guys [ __ ] your wife but
he's been [ __ ] other people
it's not about if he [ __ ] other people
there's just something about
people [ __ ] your wife
you know what i mean like i got the
title for this episode yeah like no but
like right imagine he literally was just
he came out and be like guys i'm sorry
i'm really stressed out it's like
everybody [ __ ] my wife and
and and it and i've and i [ __ ] lost
it right there i think chris would be
like dude
forgiven bro like i could see how
stressful that is if if every person
that you meet and you shake their hands
in hollywood you're like are you [ __ ]
my wife like you're not exactly sure
he's at the event where
all the people there could be [ __ ]
his wife
he has no clue everybody at that event
is looking at them going damn bruh he
just lets people [ __ ] his wife right
like what
a loser
because he's letting it happen it's not
like listen we can't control who our
wives [ __ ] right that's the reality yeah
we can't control that but if you know
and let it happen
oh
god
there's the whole tupac thing and
everything came back out tupac's dead
bro and and
he's still alive
still alive thanks to jada bro there's a
thing that came out that there's there's
a letter that [ __ ] uh
willow
the daughter wrote to who i don't even i
don't even know i don't even know that's
gonna [ __ ] daughter wrote
her daughter
yo this woman is a sorceress bro
this woman is a sorceress i know voodoo
i've never seen that kind of sorcery
this is that's some next level [ __ ] this
is next time
[ __ ] yeah no that's crazy you have to
imagine what will represent it too
will was my hero
will was my hero i remember being in
ethiopia and i i i was watching arab
satellite tv and they had three shows
they had first ones up in there they had
they had the jimmy fox show where yeah
the jimmy [ __ ] fire okay carried that
whole show he was absolutely incredible
johnny's a legend
and then they had they have the fresh
prince of bella i used to watch episodes
all the time everybody knew about them
just watching him today and just seeing
how like this fragile he looks and it
really is sad yeah it is absolutely sad
and you see the way the wife kind of
just drove and
i didn't want to believe it when she was
doing the red table talk stuff before
she's watching how far it's come now
yeah
straight up weirdo so remember when he
called her out on cheating and she kind
of gave him attitude the entanglement
son when i saw that i was like that's
weird something's off here yeah you
[ __ ] your son's friend
yo that's the way
you're recovering yeah oh yeah but she
all honest yeah
that's crazy you [ __ ] your son's
friend yeah and and
what happened i i had an entanglement
with wrong like [ __ ] you know what
happened i got a little thing like shut
up it was that i was like will's got to
get out will's out of that marriage
within three years guaranteed i don't
think so yeah guarantee i don't think so
you know
he's broken he's miserable he said
something after the first marriage he
said like when that happened that [ __ ]
was like one of the worst points in my
life and he said i i refuse to quit on
this thing i'd rather die
quit and i think what we just saw was a
man who would rather die
yeah he'd rather go up and slap other
people for the slightest words rather
than divorce his wife you're seeing a
sensible solution coming from a like
sensible frame he's saying when i said
till death it was parts bit i meant it i
said whoever you want to [ __ ] i'm
slapping [ __ ] out here in these
streets because they said something
crazy that's what you're seeing she's
just gonna start [ __ ] bigger guys too
like dudes that dudes he can't slap you
know what i mean dude imagine walking
home and your wife's just getting her
[ __ ] head smashed into the wall dude
like and you have to hear it
like
like it's you know what i'm saying like
you're on your compound in calabasas and
you just hear and he's making her come
and you can't make her calm like dude
it's just foul right
you wouldn't make me nervous
he's reading [ __ ] self-help books
like the subtle art are not giving a
[ __ ] like i love you yeah
watch the movie
seven pounds
you know whose bone is really dense
august alcena
go get your machine
imagine how nervous as a father he must
be every time his son says i'm bringing
a friend over for him yeah no yeah
how many friends you got yeah
i think fame is really weird fame is
weird and all that hollywood [ __ ] is
filled because angels are we trying to
[ __ ] jaden too
that was just them
i think she was just being like cute
like girls do that all the time i don't
know about all that stuff
honestly you know i don't think so i
think that she was just being like i
think women will do that because there's
absolutely no uh no arm no yeah there's
no harm and also like no way of like
misconstruing it i think it's like a
girl saying like oh my god look how
handsome your younger brother is i don't
think she was actually like sexually
attracted and if she was sexually
attracted in a legal way she's not going
to share it on a [ __ ] interview i
don't know i don't know i think women
can say that kind of stuff about younger
men that passes
if a dude was like old news talking
about young women that way then it looks
a little sus yeah yeah i'm we're
agreeing yeah like women can say and
then we don't assume it's something bad
we don't assume that yeah
jada's what [ __ ] her her son's best
friend who's recovering and that's super
sus
what you mean do you think if will was
[ __ ] [ __ ] the
willow's best friend yeah
fresh out of rehab
that sucks bro
i i i think also the reaction to it was
like something that people
i mean i saw a bunch of trash twitter
takes like they were really popular like
why do we need canadians with more of
these things
these folks think they can get away with
anything and [ __ ] like that and
what what what you're seeing with this
stuff is the same thing you're seeing
with speech in general just like i don't
like what you're saying like
yeah political opinions jokes it doesn't
matter if i feel some type of way and i
even heard something right i think al
was saying that on your podcast he's
saying like listen you can't control how
people react yeah and some similar along
those lines maybe yeah yeah and to me it
kind of stuck out to me a little bit
because
i feel like
i get that you can't control people
react but doesn't mean that we should
condone or accept a bunch of these
ways of reacting you know what i'm
saying of course like if somebody's
gonna be funny like they're like what a
violent reaction to a joke
say something back
like that's legal you're allowed to talk
back yes yeah you make fun of him say
the worst thing you could possibly say
to that person and then he shouldn't be
able to slap you either
and then just keep on sparring verbally
but the second you escalate the thing to
something illegal which is assault like
it is what it is you know i guess people
are really that afraid of jokes that
they don't feel like they could come
back with something i hated the fact
that folk says i'm like oh it's his wife
it's like the [ __ ] is a celebrity
they're sitting in the front row at an
event where people get made fun of she's
a celebrity yeah you guys would not say
that we can't critique celebrities make
fun of them say anything about the
celebrities oh [ __ ] you're bringing the
food out like he's going to eat it right
now [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hold on hold on hold on
let me don't put that too close without
me trying it man come on come on oh now
now you want to try it i just want to
see bruh
yeah you got a bunch of stones and sand
in those boxes you know
you [ __ ] keep that garbage about to
be a bunch of
a bunch of haitians hollering at you
like yo you trying to see some rocks
insane where are you miami calm down bro
i got your address of your studio i'll
send some family over come on stop
what's it whatever
[Laughter]
all right all right what do we got right
here
what's this plantain
you you came into your [ __ ] much later
because you're what night 39 38 38. so
you started popping up popping out last
three four years right yeah i mean like
i've
i've had like waves
i've had waves yeah like i was i had
success on tv pretty early in my career
okay yeah and then after that kind of
died down for a little bit yep then i
did the podcast thing with charlotte and
then we kind of built that but like yeah
the first way of my career was was doing
like uh tv shows i just had a bunch of
tv shows
and then uh did some acting stuff and
that kind of stuff yeah that was that
was that a time where you felt like you
had access to money or was it just like
enough to be like above i thought i had
money okay and then i made real money
yeah and i was like yeah i didn't even
have money back then
but yeah
yeah yes yeah it's different money's
just a fascinating thing like what it
exposes in you like what you really want
like i don't really buy
fancy stuff i mean
i can do things that i want to do
obviously easier but my whole thing with
money is like i just want to be able to
unplug from the matrix like
i want to get to that level of wealth
where
i don't have to do anything everything i
do is because i want to do it
and right now
i i have money but i'm i have to work
like i have to work ever i have to
continue doing it to maintain the
lifestyle and continue building and be
able to take care of my family you know
my wife's family etc so it's like
how what is the number where i can just
go you know what tuesday i don't want to
do anything tuesday
what is the number where i get to unplug
from the system where i get off the
hamster wheel i've chosen a career where
i love what i do so it's like the best
hamster wheel ever like i i dream to be
on the wheel i wake up in the morning
like you're running but you got it
like i love it what would you even do if
you unplugged the same [ __ ]
that's my whole point it's like is there
really even an unplugged
it's just a human
yeah it's just a rare thing in the human
existence to be able to
be so financially secure that everything
you do in your life is because you want
to do it not because you have to
and i just want to taste that as part of
you know this short time i have here on
earth i want to see what it's like to be
like okay what's wrong with having to do
stuff
honestly like nothing and our brains are
probably built to have to do it i'm just
curious what happens to your brain when
you don't have sometimes you just want
to get off you want to you want to take
off you don't want to take time off you
just want to unplug you want to be able
to because
you plug whenever you unplug you still
have to
think about whenever you go back yeah i
never 100 unplug because i'm still
thinking about should i have to i have
to go back and i don't never never
really unplug because even every time i
unplug
every time that i unplugged
some [ __ ] happened and we had to do
something
we had some some some [ __ ] happen and i
had to wire myself back to the matrix
because i we had to do some [ __ ] whether
it was remote whether it was alive
whether it was whatever so when i'm off
i'm not off completely because i got
i got another thing going i got i got to
think about other things sometimes you
just want to really unplug not have to
and see how you create there like
when you're unplugged you might create
differently you might be inspired to do
different things say different things
you don't have the stress of the time
you don't have the stress it's a
different way of working in a different
way of thinking but
yeah but we could also experience that
and then we could we could go oh this is
no different than being plugged and then
you just go back to be plugged but at
least you know that yeah right it's kind
of fun to know these things i don't know
my whole thing is like we have a short
time on this on this planet right and
like there's certain biology that's
built into us and i just want to reach
the limits of that i want to see what
happens like okay you get a little money
you get comfortable is my motivation
still there am i still hungry do i want
to take over do i want to topple
everything am i still competitive yeah
okay that was cool to find out
what have you discovered myself do you
feel like you're more competitive more
ambitious
nothing changes
yeah nothing changes i do find that like
i'm i'm happy with my disposition with
money like i i
when i more successful i try to reward
the people who have contributed to that
success and i and i'm
and you you you figure those things out
when you get there you're like you'll
get money you're like okay do i pay my
guys more
and if i was i was happy like that was
my inclination i was also happy that
like i was very excited for my guy's
success you know like seeing akash
really start to sell tickets and do well
with the specials and all this kind of
stuff like i was really excited for him
and i think that
there are situations where people are
jealous
and it's like you don't know that until
you're in it yeah and i was i was like i
had a cool moment where i was like this
is awesome like i'm really excited that
my brother
is living his dream and
yeah that was just really cool so seeing
those things seeing like who you really
are
in these environments i think is a cool
you know it's a it's a cool experience
human experience the talking [ __ ] is
real though
talking [ __ ] you know i mean
noticing [ __ ] talk like what do
you really think
when they realize and when they start
calculating you yeah oh you got that and
that and that means that you got that oh
when they start counting your pockets
yeah when you start calculating your
pockets now you see the real talking
[ __ ] you're like oh that's how you feel
yeah that's like okay all right like i'm
pretty sure that if this [ __ ] like
happened
if this [ __ ] would have happened like 10
years ago i would have felt something i
would have been very bothered about it
yeah i would have been a different
person and throw hands and [ __ ] like
that really what that [ __ ] you say
walk up to [ __ ] definitely but
now you got too much [ __ ] to lose
exactly so i just calm myself down i do
call myself that but back then yeah
popping off was not an issue yeah cause
you didn't i mean i don't know what you
had back then but like when you have
things to lose you have a business you
have a relationship it's like you know i
mean it's like it's so much
harder
like that's why will was such a [ __ ]
idiot
that's exactly what i was thinking right
like you know
let's go it goes no it's like it's a lot
of people on the internet they're like
yeah you gotta protect your wife and
it's just like how do you protect her by
going to jail stupid yes like
by not being able to work because it
really reinforces the idea that men's
like show of love and gratitude is by
being like what physically [ __ ]
violence yeah what are you talking about
so who's gonna pay the bills who's gonna
protect you when i'm literally not
physically present yeah and i'm saying
like [ __ ] it's easy to say that because
this man got away with it
you slap most people like that it's a
fight afterwards and you're going to
jail for assault it's not going to just
be battery it's not allowed you're going
to jail for assault like is that is that
love to you to me like just sometimes
when i hear [ __ ] like that i'm like do
you not recognize like what you're
expecting from your partner for them to
risk like putting their whole life
getting a criminal record all this
[ __ ] for what because you couldn't
handle a [ __ ] joke and it's serious
and it's [ __ ] up because that's crazy
[ __ ] up because i didn't hear one talk
all the [ __ ] i've been talking
about that toxic masculinity weren't
talking now because if you're according
to what you're saying that [ __ ] was
toxic yeah but i hear no [ __ ]
he's like no he's protecting his wife
and blah blah blah and like no that
let's let's put that [ __ ] in the
that's that's that's
in the pot
yeah with the rest of it yeah in their
defense
i understand how a lot of women out
there may have been with people who felt
like they never had their backs when it
mattered right yeah i could understand
that those women seeing that in that
moment said i wish my partner would have
taken care of me when i was being right
by people right you didn't have my back
so they see that you see that as a
beautiful thing but they don't even
understand how warped that is and like
wanting that is okay but expecting what
will did in those kind of circumstances
like you want your partner to go to jail
for you and it makes me realize like a
lot of ladies out there don't understand
the implications of violence they don't
understand like what it means when two
dudes do that in general
because it's fine for them i do that to
most people i know we go and edit it
what happens if they got weapons on them
or some [ __ ] like that happens it's best
believer if i start punching somebody
and they got a concealed carry they go
pull out their gun yeah so it's just the
expectation of that is crazy
it's crazy i told you i've been
rummaging on this the whole weekend it
just like it was like a lot of different
flash points for me but
i i said this i think for a lot of folks
in north america this thing is going to
be bigger than whatever is happening
yeah
and we're glad
was it because we don't want to talk
about that
we were faking being interested in that
yeah and this is like way on our this is
like way closer to our like intellect
level
you know what i mean like this is
so we're so excited that we get to
pretend to be to stop we have to stop
pretending to be these like you know
geopolitical experts yeah we're not
we're not but we just want to gossip and
then gossip got two [ __ ] high stakes
we need kardashians we need you know
random [ __ ] talk
yeah that is what we're great at in
america because life is good here
so we need goofy [ __ ] to talk about yeah
we don't want the real high stakes stuff
yeah that [ __ ] was serious serious their
ukrainian stuff is serious yeah until
russia is on their shores like i don't
care yeah until they if until they
drafting [ __ ]
yeah i'm just chilling in the back i'm
just feeling the back i'm not even
trying to pay attention to that but this
stuff yeah
did you outside of the the comic angle
was there any aspect of that that really
kind of stood out to you
about the will of jada thing yeah
i mean i was just so disappointed
because chris rock is my hero and and
will smith was my hero and they i mean
it was just like i'm seeing both of
these guys in the light that i don't
like to see him i didn't think chris
looked great either to be honest with
you now a lot of people kept saying that
that's really
he's being professional no no no no he
was having like you said he was having a
bad set yeah yeah yeah
when you said that i felt that i felt
that inside when we played the video and
said that nigga's having a rough set and
i was like let me say this that moment
is going to define the oscars probably
for the next 10 years
or backwards there is literally not a
more iconic moment in award show history
than that nothing before that i think it
was like
kanye jumping on stage
but beyonce had their greatest yes
and that's grammys yeah and that's
graeme those grammys are mtv's yeah but
i'm just talking about awards in general
this is the greatest
moment whatever but like like next i
don't think i think next year there's
not even going to be oscars yeah
they stopped the opposition
they gonna do it what you said you said
um
it was sad for you because you think
kristin looked good yeah i don't think
chris looked great like i understand
what he was managing or i assume again i
don't know man but like i assume he's
managing his relationships in hollywood
and he's like i if i just fight someone
at the oscars i might not get to be in
[ __ ] zootopia or like doing these
movies that i'm doing and he doesn't
wanna he doesn't necessarily wanna fight
will well there's also that but like he
also didn't just roast the [ __ ] out of
him right because he's like i'm not
going to make this more of a scene and i
think that he wasn't like i have to look
out for the oscars i'm sure that there's
you know some personal benefit there
it's like i i also have relationships
here and i want to show this
professionalism i've been punched on
stage
it throws you off for sure right like
it's something
i've been punched on stage
like i was in the stand up and i got
punched me i got up and went on stage
well i wasn't on stage i was at like
this
so new york there's like i don't know if
you guys have this [ __ ] out here but
they're like they call like the hood
room circuit right so it's not like
it's not that that's the polite way the
chitlin circuit is what they call it
right
it's basically the black clubs right and
uh so there's one uh smokey shout out to
smokey suarez i mean he's just this
legendary comic in new york and he ran a
room called cafe mocha uptown
and uh i it was i was young in comedy i
was in you know i was just
learning the game and i went up and uh i
didn't really care about doing hood
rooms and i heard like i grew up in new
york like it wasn't like a big deal for
me to like see not white people in the
crowd like it just wasn't shocking but i
understand if you're coming from like
maine and you come to new york to be a
comic like there's like two scenes to
you does that make sense yes okay
so like uh but i was like yeah okay i'll
just go to the show and i'm making fun
of some puerto rican guy and keep in
mind this isn't like you're at comedy
clubs you're like a bar so you're
performing kind of like in front of the
bar like people can get up use the
bathroom they got the [ __ ] knicks
game on the tv it's it's wild
and uh i was making fun of his dudes
puerto rican dude that wasn't funny i
was just kind of like busting his balls
it was early on and he got up and he
walked up to me and i was like what's up
like i didn't understand what was
happening like is he getting a drink is
he
fighting like what the [ __ ] is going on
he's standing in front of me and i'm
like what's up and then he swings on me
right
they grabbed him and then they grabbed
me
luckily for me before i could do nothing
they grabbed me right because i wasn't
going to do anything uh
so
i got bailed out like that hold me back
like this
thank god i was very good and uh
because i'm in [ __ ] harlem at this
guy's home you can live upstairs like
i'm i'm i'm in a place where i don't
know where i'm good right
so
you don't know who i don't know who's
there i mean this is like the
neighborhood spot it's not like people
take calves here it's like you live
around here you come through you got
cousins around here boom so
i so basically they grab him they threw
him out and then i remember smokey uh
hand me the mic he was like all right
man keep doing your thing
and
but and i and i and i roasted him a
little bit he was gone but still like i
addressed what happened i didn't go i'm
gonna be professional go back into my
jokes i address what happened and then i
went have fun i went back there the next
week and and it was all good but the
first reaction when you get punched in a
place where you're not expecting it at
all
is not
okay now it's on we're fighting we're
scrapping the first reaction is what the
[ __ ] just happened shock shock
absolute
shock
and so i i i have tons of empathy for
chris for that it's what happened after
that i was bummed like when will was
telling him keep your wife's name on my
mouth he was like i will
you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] that
i won't
you know what i'm saying i will say
these jokes about your wife and there
was a moment where he almost lit him up
he goes he goes um
he goes keep my wife's name out of your
mouth and chris goes chris goes
and he had something in the chamber
and he was ready to let that [ __ ] rip
and i wish he did bro
i wish he did
i think he was really just more shocked
it was just shock
you don't you host
the oscars oh yeah yeah yeah
you do not
expect to get death in the mouth and
then nothing happened like this nobody
says [ __ ]
no security nothing nobody rushed then
nothing he breathing the teleprompter
like no i was it was wild disrespectful
oscars yeah
didn't they give willow innovation
money yeah imagine being backstage and
they gave this [ __ ]
so how do you feel so it's it's they
hate chris rock he's been making fun of
all them for the last decade they were
happy that chris did that i mean it will
did that
all the people in that room were
improving for chris
these people never get made fun of in
their life they never get pushed back in
their life and then one day a year
because they need the validation of
being at the oscars they put themselves
in the line of fire in the line the guy
who's firing the bullets is off in chris
rock and they hate it and it drives them
[ __ ] crazy and they love to see him
get slapped
but i think you're 100 accurate but yeah
it's gross it was gross it was gross but
you know what we can't even just say
hollywood's gross because a lot of
people online were cheering that [ __ ] on
like it was [ __ ] fantastic so i
refuse to just put on hollywood because
no the people are like really think
that's just
people people think that shit's kosher
people think going up to slap somebody
you disagree with or fighting the
physical violence is acceptable why do
you say coach or not halal
you know because i'm an infidel
[Laughter]
he left
he left the halal life a long time ago
it's like i don't even pretend like you
listen i grew up in that but i'm not
about that life so it already said i get
people message me all the time
you know you're going to find your way
back to allah one day
i'm masturbating right now
they really think they're challenging
[ __ ] or or pushing someone or
going to someone and i don't know if
it's a culture that they think that
nothing is going to happen
no they think that their feelings matter
more than anything
that's what i've literally heard people
say you can't control people react you
can't
expect people to act a certain way uh if
you say something some might happen
people just say that i'm not disagreeing
but people say that like it's a defense
yeah that's what kills me
i know when i walk you see some [ __ ]
might pop off i'm not mad i understand
that
when i was watching somebody punch me
well [ __ ] might happen
is that your first response yeah you get
what i'm saying well it's yeah it's you
know what it's mine you know what it's
like this is what it's like
i was raped what were you wearing
yeah yeah that's the same thing yeah
and but i'm seeing it all over i'm like
bro y'all are bugging yeah
that's interesting it's like yeah you
don't know how people could react to you
wearing something like that
that's what they're saying that's that's
what they're saying interesting that's
what they think well she had alopecia
i'm like bro y'all killing me right now
did he know no he didn't know nobody
even knew she even had a ball to your
whole career like set it off she
literally shaved her head at the end of
the movie even even if he did know
also what's alopecia it's like why is it
a disease when we go bald it's an
autoimmune disease she's not even fully
bought she got a couple patches yeah so
she shaved it off but i digress all this
to say i don't know for me just
it doesn't matter
just know but i think we'll wrap it up
there yeah if you guys enjoyed today's
episode you already know what to do make
sure you leave those likes in those
comments in the comments below uh and
andrew thank you for coming on yo thank
you guys for having me i love what you
guys do man we won't finish your food
anytime i'm not fashion
send that back to haiti
you know what happened with the last
time live vice president told me to send
something back to haiti what happened
yeah i challenged him to the fight they
challenged me and what happened they
pussied out they pussied out yeah well
[ __ ] bro just remember if you ever
challenged me i still got the machetes
at the [ __ ] hold on wait i got
something too bring yours i'll bring
mine that's where you came in was it odd
was it on video where you're like no no
you said so [ __ ] you're like yeah i
collect machetes i like them i was like
that's one of the most terrifying things
i've ever heard in my life
i could like guns now
and he's like yeah it's a good farming
tool
[Laughter]
i love you guys man thank you guys for
having me